[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you just tapped into the new season of
group chat live in the bleacher report
app presented by fanduel i'm greg ivory
alongside the lovely aaron dolan it's
week two of the nba season aaron
what has been the most important lesson
you've learned so far after a week of
games
what's up greg i would say the most
important lesson is it is week two do
not overreact just yet also now that we
have data and information provided on
certain player props and things like
that seeing how teams play against the
spread you can use all this information
to make better picks so better be on the
fanduel sports book and start placing
those bets
place those bets
we're giving away hoodies we're giving
away jerseys matter of fact the first
one is going out now aaron you want to
get in the app and hook somebody up with
the hoodie right now
yes so greg's allowing me to use the
handy-dandy iphone he uses the ipad
allowed to pick somebody i'm going to go
enderman
i-n-d-e-r-m-a-n i like the giphy so
we're gonna rock with you with the first
hoodie
hey shout out to enderman aaron has just
hooked you up with the hoodie but not
only are we giving away hoodies at the
top of the show we're giving out a
jersey so aaron i'm in the comments now
giving away a jersey
and
i see i see
aaron a rings22 a-rings22 says jans fans
here knowing mpj is gonna go off tonight
i have i have heard that mpj is gonna go
off tonight that's what a lot of people
have been dming me on instagram so shout
out to a rings22 you are walking away
with 125 to buy whatever jersey that you
want to aaron it's tnt tuesday meaning
fanduel is running our favorite bet
the 3x2 for both games tonight the
question is will there be two three
pointers in the first three minutes of
the game we asked you on twitter which
three by two will cash tonight
will it be the sixers
taking on the knicks or will it be the
nuggets take it on the jazz
here are the results aaron here are the
results there it is this is a close one
this is a close one your sixers taking
on the nick sitting at 47
utah taking on denver sitting at 53
uh i need you guys to get in the
comments and tell me which 3x2 is a lot
tonight
let's get creative i need some gifts i
need emojis but most importantly i need
everybody right now comment comment
winners only please i'll give out a
hoodie to a commenter that i see uh run
those comments up but aaron
what's 3x2 do you like better which 3x2
do you like better philly new york
denver utah
uh philly new york plus money i have to
go with that now last game seth curry
had six made three pointers in that
first quarter this of course against
it was against the thunder which is not
the new york knicks inside madison
square garden but nick 748 he has the
most made three pointers for them
derrick bros can pull up so i'm gonna
rock with that first game plus the plus
money it also is my team which does
indeed help but i know you're kind of
you're gonna go with that later game
right
i might i might go with that later game
but you always accuse me of being a
hometown fan
but i know you're partial to those sixes
eric
i i know you're partial to those sixers
uh let me hop in the comments why not
i'll just hop into the comments
uh mt nuggs fan says
jazz shoot the three really well shout
out to you you were walking away with
hoodie i got stripe giraffe eight says
winners only he did not say the please
but that is okay we are showing good
vibes shout out to you striped draft
eight you were walking away with a
hoodie uh
aaron
i see the comments are jumping today the
the comments are jumping today 80
diff83 says sixers versus nix he's
riding with you
uh i'll just hop in here i'll give my
take i'm riding with denver utah just
because i don't want to go with the same
pick as you are and i want to go on the
other side and i want to see what the
comments are going to pick so uh the
next commenter that i see we're just
going to ride that 3x2 together as a
family okay aaron
okay let's see it here we go
i'm going to scroll here we go
julio hernandez he gave us a good take
he says hey aaron and greg the jazz and
nuggets will hit the 3x2 so many
shooters all over the floor especially
with yoker and go burr in the middle
it'll open up the floor for everyone
else to get open early shout out to my
guy julio hernandez for the take that
was a real good
take and he explained everything
perfectly for us so we are riding
we are riding aaron we are riding denver
versus utah three by two as a family uh
shout out to julio man that was a really
good take let's move on aaron we asked
you in the app how many points will joel
embiid score tonight against the knicks
get in the comments and tell me how many
points embiid is putting up at the end
of the game will dm one person who gets
closest and hook you up with the jersey
aaron embiid is sitting at 26 and a half
points how do you feel about that number
so you know i love the philadelphia
76ers i'm a huge huge fan of joel embiid
so it pains me to say under 26 and a
half he's averaging 21 points so far
this season he's only posted 22 19 22 in
the last three games and also this is
inside madison square garden now if this
was inside wells fargo i would probably
take the over but when you see madison
square garden rockin it is tough for me
to kind of you know have one player have
a huge standout performance that is not
on the new york knicks team so i'm gonna
go with the under 26 and a half for
tonight
wow
i am surprised by that aaron
i am very very surprised i thought that
you were gonna rock with joelle in the
over being that philly is your team uh
but let me hop into the comments and see
what they're talking about i got ka wash
13 saying under for sure rocking with
you aaron shout out to you ka wash 13
you were walking away with a hoodie uh
dub 303 says joelle enjoys the garden
joelle enjoys the garden
aaron uh so shout out to uw 303 um
23 22 goldie says embiid 35 points
tonight and i'm going to stop there i'm
going to stop there uh i'm not going to
go with 22 goldie uh i'm not going to go
with 22 goldie but i'm going to go with
you aaron i'm going to go with under 26
and a half uh he's facing that knicks
defense they've been playing tough and
like you said this game is at madison
square guard it is not at home and i see
embiid is going to have a tough matchup
tonight against those knicks uh and he's
going to go under that point total
remember
something
i mean yeah we're on the same page let's
go remember we're going to hit one of
you guys up after the game and hook you
guys up with a jersey but i got more
jerseys to give away right now so let's
roll to this next segment aaron we just
talked embiid i mean you are a philly
native the sixers are your team seems
like a lot of mess is going on out there
in philadelphia
but they do have two wins on the board
aaron
what's your take with all this ben
simmons drama
well i'm happy we have two wins without
ben simmons because i'm so sick and
tired of hearing about the drama i've
had people dm me from the parking lot of
wells fargo pinatas with ben simmons
space on it now i know joel embiid
before the one uh game at home had said
you know ben simmons is still our
brother this is obviously much different
than some of the press conferences that
he's done the drama is absolutely
ridiculous it's affecting the team it
has to be i'm sick and tired of talking
about it but clearly it's still relevant
because it's also impacting the odds
it is impacting the odds it's impacting
on the floor and it's impacting the team
off the floor and it's also
impacting the betting market aaron uh
let's take a look at these philly odds
there it is uh is there anything here
you would bet eric
so just one thing i wanted to know to
win the nba championship 20 to one that
has not moved whatsoever to win the
division plus 350 they're behind the
nets who are at minus 260 right now in
the fanduel sports book i think out of
all of these markets that are on the
board right now and b twin mvp i know
that has moved out it's still 14 to one
if he's able to put up a ton of points a
ton of rebounds we know he was runner-up
to nicola yokic and last season nicole
yokic was a long shot before the season
so a big man can win it so i think if
you sprinkle some money on embiid to win
mvp at a better price 14-1 i do like
that out of all of the things that were
on the board just there
i like that too erin i like that too we
do know joel embiid is the alpha in
philadelphia and uh if he stays healthy
i can see him potentially being in that
mpp race but let's pull those odds back
up because i want to show you guys a lot
let me show you guys a lot you guys see
that minus 2200 uh to make the playoffs
i think that that is a lot i do think
the philadelphia 76ers will make the
playoffs but i'm not telling you to bet
the minus two hundred and two the minus
two thousand and two hundred uh bet i
like the one right above it to win the
division plus 350 i mean we are talking
about the philadelphia 76ers and they
have won games without ben simmons this
team is deep uh i do think that they can
go pull that off and win the division at
plus 350 if i had to take a bet here uh
let me hop into the comments though let
me hop into the comments and give away
some hoodies i got
jacob pastor 13 says greg ben simmons is
a problem in this locker room a trade
should be considered aaron i know you
like that take
a trade could be but i think who we're
going to get right now
it's tough i would love to get the man
lillard i would love to get bradley beal
but i mean ben's put it shooting himself
in the foot even for a trade at this
point nobody wants to deal with him
my guy deke geek is in the comments deep
geek is in the comments saying simmons
is good not great the drama is making
them worse than simmons playing would
make them better none of those bets are
worth taking winners only please jersey
hook up please i don't know if i can get
you a jersey deep geek but i can get you
probably your 10th hoodie uh so shout
out to you for your take really
appreciate it aaron the sixers are your
team so i'm gonna let you pick a
commenter to win a hoodie get into those
comments and give a lucky fan a hoodie
okay who we're going to give it to um g
hernandez 31 ben simmons needs to go too
much drama they need to replace him i
agree with you so for that reason you're
getting a hoodie congrats
shout out to eugene uh you are walking
away with the hoodie aaron as you know
last week i went to the lakers warriors
game with my man metal world peace and
watched the warriors
win
then we all saw this mess happen in the
sun's game with the lakers check this
out
anthony goes over to dwight when dwight
stands up anthony my brother
dwight
yeah but after that aaron after that
magic johnson actually dropped this
tweet right here check this one out he
says the lakers have a team
and
basketball issue i need you to get in
the comments and tell me if you think
the lakers are going to recover this
year aaron what's your take are the
lakers doomed they got one win on the
board against memphis but it's not
looking too good in la
yeah this was obviously a heated
exchange now i think we also put so much
hype onto this team coming into the
preseason which is why it's making it
even worse and i'm sure they know what
type of pressure they are under as well
i'm not saying they're looking at the
fanduel sports book at the odds and
saying oh my gosh everyone's expecting
us to win but on paper they're so good
but this comes back to you can have a
ton of stars on a team but really do you
have that chemistry
that should not be happening on the
court ever especially when your
teammates take it to the locker room i'm
sure that happens all the time in the
locker room but to publicly kind of do
that knowing all the cameras are on you
and then to lose the game
is kind of unfortunate i think they'll
be able to bounce back the oddsmaker is
still agreeing i think with me that
there's still a team that's going to be
a contender again it's only two weeks
into the nba season
it's only two weeks into the nba season
i mean the team full of hall of famers
you might have a team full of egos so we
will see what happens in la let's take a
look at the current laker odds they are
still favorites to win the west and
second favorites to win the finals
do you still think those are good bets
after what we've seen so far any markets
you like here aaron
so to win the nba finals this has
remained around what it was pre-season
um to win the division plus 155 i think
is something that you would want to
maybe look at i think lebron to an mvp
wouldn't be his year per se neither
would anthony davis maybe look at him
more for sixth man of the year but just
over all the lakers i mean oh and three
against the spread it's kind of tough
for me to
really give a great take on one of these
markets that i like but again i think
you just monitor these lines over the
next couple of weeks with them
well i'll i'll be i'll be frank i'll
i'll be honest uh if we can pull that
graphic back up one time because i just
want to walk through it i just want to
walk through it and just be blunt with
you guys they're not winning the finals
because yeah they're not winning the
finals they're not winning the west i
think the golden state warriors are
going to win the best i don't know if
they're going to win the division to
make the play-in tournament and not
going to touch it but i do see lebron to
win mvp and that right there
catches my attention uh braun's sitting
at plus 1500
i'll sprinkle something on that i mean
we're talking about lebron james the
goat sitting that plus 1500 i'll
sprinkle something on that so that will
be my take on those laker odds but let
me hop into
the comments aaron let me hop into the
comments because i'm giving away a
jersey and a hoodie this time um
i got i got i got enderman back enderman
is back with a gif of steph
clay and my guy
draymond uh dabbing shouts out to you
enderman uh rocky with the warriors here
we go i see eric eric
art no eric reiner eric reiner says the
lakers will catch on farther into the
season they need to build chemistry and
it will happen
third seed in the west shout out to you
eric
matter of fact that deserves a jersey
eric reinhardt you are walking away with
a jersey of your choice i got to give
away a hoodie right here aaron uh
i see
i see
a lot of takes in the comments show show
ss77 says these guys are pros they will
figure it out in lebron we trust show
essa 77 you are walking away
with a hoodie uh
aaron let's talk about rookie of the
year let's keep this thing going let's
talk about rookie of the year
green
jaylen green hit eight three-pointers
against the celtics
setting the rockets franchise record for
three-pointers made by rookie he also
tied the nba record for most threes by a
teenager in a single game sharing the
record with anthony edwards he also made
this crazy dunk check this one out aaron
look at this he gets the outlet pass
right over jason tatum
philadelphia 76ers jersey but we didn't
take him
conversation hey tatum
tatum was smart the the sixers might
have not been smart taking uh jason
tatum but tatum was smart in that
particular play by not jumping he stayed
on his feet but green remains the
favorite to win rookie of the year get
in the comments and tell me if you think
it's too early to say green is a lock
who is your favorite pick to win rookie
of the year uh let's take a look at the
odds aaron what are you thinking about
rookie of the year so jalen green plus
240 not surprised he's moved down he's
averaging 16 points four rebounds three
assists so far despite the rockets only
being one and two he does look good but
considering that cade cunningham hasn't
played just yet and he's plus 380 still
down there on the odds board shows me
that the odds makers still think that
some of these other players could
potentially be able to beat a jalen
green which they have some you know
stats and what not to go off of and
price that but obviously there's still
long shots you can take it is week two
health and availability still a huge
thing so i'm not surprised that jalen
greene has moved down that far but i
still think that oddsmakers are going to
continue to move this market a lot over
the next couple of weeks
you mentioned long shots aaron you
mentioned long shots and i love that you
mentioned that in fact because uh davion
mitchell that's sitting at plus 1600
uh i talked about him last week and i'm
gonna stay on the daveon mitchell train
they call him off night for a reason
aaron they call him off night for a
reason for his defense his defensive uh
presence that he has out there on the on
the floor
he got off to a rocky start shooting in
the nba erin
but his last start against the golden
state words he put up 22 points on nine
of 16
shooting the rocks taking off the nerve
shaking he's just shaking exactly
shaking off the nerves i do think the
game will begin to slow down for him and
the offensive numbers will keep going up
and up and up so i'm gonna rock with my
guy davion mitchell to win rookie of the
year but
i'm back into the comments i am back
into the comments giving away hoodies
hey i just want to mention i'm not
giving away hoodies to people that are
repeating the the same comment you're
spamming the comments uh i'm looking for
new takes interesting takes and good
takes only uh i got
goats gardening
go garden says jalen will win aaron he
says jalen will win the rookie of the
year uh oh i see another one chris
duarte
k-i-r-y hawkins a-i-r-y hawkins that is
for the producers chris duarte is a
sleeper for sure aaron talk to me
he is a sleeper have you seen him uh
seen him early on in the season he's
been bawling
yeah i mean the tough part about
watching some of the rookies just in
general also is that they usually aren't
on great teams so you don't want to
really be following those teams i'm
talking about the cavs the pistons
things like that but yeah i mean like
you mentioned the long shots i think
that's the way to go in this type of
market because like i mentioned over the
next couple of weeks this is going to
continue to change we saw so much change
just from last week
that's that is a fact that is a fact uh
shout out to everybody that i mentioned
you guys are walking away with the
hoodie i also see uh
g quinn 24 says green bean he's got the
nicest shot out of all the rookies so uh
i mean shout out to everybody that i
mentioned you guys are all walking away
with hoodies uh aaron we talked rookie
of the year now let's talk mvp so i need
everybody to get in the comments and
tell me your early favorites
erin do you have an early favorite
let's look at the odds for mvp let's
pull these up okay so last week i had
said damien lillard 18-1 i wanted to
take a shooter but look at steph curry
he's moved down to plus 600 he's
sandwiched with giannis as the
co-favorite right now then kevin
durant's behind luca doncic she was a
favorite going into the season at plus
500 he moves down then you have some big
man dwell embiid 14 to 1 nicole yokic
you won it last year 18-1 i don't think
he will repeat but i'm still going to
stick with damian miller because i think
a shooter is going to be able to do this
but again they will have to probably
score average over 30 points i just
think game out of some of the players on
the board and considering some of the
players who do and don't play
back-to-backs he is going to remain
relatively healthy from things that
we've seen throughout the last couple of
seasons so i'm going to stick with my
gut on that one but love to hear your
take greg
i love that pick aaron actually dame was
my uh my mvp pick last year and you know
he just got better this year and so i do
love the pick at plus 1800 but aaron
there's this man by the name of wardale
curry uh
and he was second on that list last week
last week he was plus 800 now he's plus
600 the odds makers are catching on so
listen to me everybody go put the bet in
now go put it in now i told you last
week it was plus 800 now it's plus 600
it's just gonna keep going down because
he's just gonna keep
being phenomenal and uh the warriors are
better this year last year i think that
steph curry should have won the mvp with
the numbers that he put up but the
warriors
barely made the eighth seed this year
they will be a better team so that will
add to the fact of steph cory or add to
the potential of seth cory uh winning
mvp uh let me buy some goodies
no bias no no no
goodbye
no bias aaron nobody's don't tell nobody
nobody
i'm in the comments though i'm in the
comments giving away hoodies to some
takes uh
knickspix13 says steph is gonna be a
menace to the league this year shout out
to you nick's pix13 you are walking away
with a hoodie i i do agree steph is
going to be a problem cdub 75 says
joelle has to do a lot to win mvp this
year aaron he says joel has to do a lot
i agree he do have to do a lot but it is
possible shout out to you cd75 for the
take aaron
i got one more jersey to give away
so it's time for our last
segment aaron this week and for the rest
of the season we're doing something very
very special
i'm building my same game parlays as
usual but now you're gonna have a chance
to ride with me i need all of you and i
mean all of you to get in the comments
and tell me what do you think of my
parlay which legs or locks which legs is
ruining the parlay and i'm gonna need
you to grade my parlay from an a to a f
i'm giving out a jersey to my favorite
take are you guys
ready aaron are you ready
yeah let's get to it
let's see
it let's get to it uh
let's go
donovan mitchell
donovan mitchell the star of utah the
star of this jazz team go score 25
points donovan i need 25 from you
tonight uh
eric this is doable right i like it it's
doable absolutely this is going to be
such a competitive game that some of
these players will stand out
good vibes good vibes loving the vibes
there aaron loving the vibes to start
this off
we're going to move on mike conley
mike conley the point guard out there in
utah aaron he likes the dish the rock he
likes the dish to rock we're gonna go
six plus assists for my guy mike conley
aaron show me the love show me the love
averaging four he's averaging four he's
averaging four that's all i'm saying he
is averaging four in the season again
that's bad
but that's that's bad vibes though no we
want this to hit i'm on board i'm on
board i'm on board go to the next one
okay all right all right you don't have
to agree with me you you i'm just saying
you don't have if you want to send those
bad vibes into the atmosphere then just
you know send them on no i want just a
hit for everybody's sake
i do
good vibes i like the vibes there aaron
we're moving on to the joker the joker
10 plus rebounds go get 10 uh
aaron i i'm just going to my next i mean
how do you feel about the 10 rebound
give me that
um he's had 41 rebounds in just two
games so love that yes
love that thank you love the good vibes
but i was just going to mention
yeah he's crazy i was going to mention
that i think that he's going to get a
triple-double and that was going to lead
me into my next take we're going to go
with the joker 6 plus assist tonight
uh
there it is aaron give me some love give
me some love do you like this one or not
yeah absolutely i mean i wouldn't be
surprised if he did have a triple double
i mean he's been carrying the team for
the last couple of games so makes sense
and it's gonna put it in the same game
mvp for a reason aaron just said this
looks like a decent okay look like a
good parlay let's see the odds let's see
the odds pull those odds up so we can
show the people
okay there's 480
plus 480 you know some slight we just
trying to see one go go through the net
you know i'm talking about we all see
one go through the net then we can start
let me start playing around a little bit
you know but we got to see one go
through aaron before i get into the
comments
what are you grading my parlay
so i'm going to grade this i was between
a b and a b minus but i'm going to bump
you up to a b because i always ask my
teachers to bump me up so i'm going to
give you a b only because plus 480 we
got to go for those long shots but i
also agree with taking some of them that
you actually think most definitely are
going to hit and getting that plus money
so i'm all for it
you did well aaron gave me a b
i'll take that bees for sure that that
that's a 3.0 so
yeah i'll i'll definitely take that
right
you're above that these definitely
bees definitely get those degrees uh
let me get into the comments let me get
into the comments i'm giving out a
jersey and i'm giving out hoodies uh
here we go
i see connolly no bueno take him out bro
from sk howeso 77 wow that is bad vibe
shout out to you you have a hoodie
already uh here we go
the big perm the big perm
says b-plus nuggets playing a
back-to-back but bouncing
may rejuvenate them okay
thank you for the b plus uh nick perm
here we go
ev reyes says b plus conley could be a
hit or miss
okay shout out to you those two desserts
it's only less
worries
what'd you say here
only leg were a little worrisome goat
garden gave you my
here we go we got king of sports 21 this
is for the jersey
this is for the jersey he says mitchell
will ball 25 should be a cakewalk conley
averages four to five steals easy we
said assist it's okay though uh
jokic 10 and six assists is easy odds
are not to juchi which should hit good
luck g money i appreciate you king of
sports 21 you just said my odds aren't
juicy but guess what i'm gonna uh
i'm gonna send good vibes your way and
hopefully juice up your day by uh
sending you a jersey of your
choice aaron you want to hop into the
comments and give a give away a hoodie
okay let's do it one last hoodie guys
hop in
all right let's see somebody somebody
dropped me a giffy i think i just passed
one some of these are coming through so
quickly i just passed one where was it
yeah
yeah the hoodies
the hoodies all right there we go we are
broke we are grove too
congratulations
yeah this jen's the show
hey shout out to br bro for dropping the
gift that is what aaron wanted she
wanted the gift and they dropped it uh
that's it aaron it's time to sign off
thanks for tapping into the group chat
presented by fandom remember what you
learned today
the denver utah 3x2 is a lock
joelle embiid is going off philly is in
trouble but there might be value on the
mb to win mvp future don't overreact to
the lakers problems
they still got hall of famers
and get on fanduel to tail my same game
parlay we'll be right back here giving
out more hoodies more jerseys and more
locks if you want a hoodie today
be our betting not greg not aaron but br
betting will dmu
and uh you know what
aaron i want you to give out one more
hoodie just for the fun of it why not
all right here we go
and
yeah first one you see
did you give one out to d geek yet
yeah he has like 20 of them
he has like 20 hoodies
say it one more time
jacob pastor 13. greg that's in jacob
pastor
that's it
jacob pastor 13 you were walking away
with a hoodie also
cjrr416 shout out to the gift right here
you were walking away with a hoodie uh
thank you
thank you thank you uh get on fanduel
ride with us and follow us on social
alongside the lovely aaron dolan i'm
greg ivory we are leaving the group chat
peace
see ya
[Music]
so
[Music]
you